mansion previously held the line but now
he's doing exactly what he said he would
not do he has now folded to the far left
climate cult that represents his party
here with reaction fox news contributors
jason chaffetz and charlie hurt
congressman we start with you get your
take on this
i really believed mansion understood
that what the democrats were proposing
would hurt his state in particular
i was pretty shocked to hear he's going
along with the build back broke new
green deal madness but he is
he is and this is what's shocking you
know manchin was put up there as the the
one person who is uh with kirsten cinema
that was holding back the dam but it to
the good people of west virginia you got
snookered you got taken to the cleaners
because this week alone just this week
he has
recklessly added more spending more than
700 billion dollars in more spending is
that going to help you at the gas tank
is that going to help you with inflation
no and he raised taxes on everybody's
going to feel that in west virginia and
the coal industry also got a tax
increase so good luck going back and
explaining that shelly moore capito she
got it right but joe manchin don't
believe that he thinks he stands on
principle he raises taxes spends like a
democrat and the people of this country
are going to pay the price especially
there in west virginia i am so
disappointed in this guy he talks a good
game but then when he push comes to
shove he just folds like a house of
cards you know charlie as i look at this
objectively i just cannot wrap my mind
around the idea without any real
alternative they say well we're gonna
we'll be energy independent with
renewables we don't have that technology
or capacity and we won't for the next 10
to 20 years at a minimum
but it's okay to import oil from
countries that that hate us
give up energy independence it would be
better for national security high paying
career jobs we we literally would be
back to two dollar a gallon gasoline and
we could be the biggest producer of
energy and bail out western europe and
their their energy needs and become the
wealthiest country on earth and pay next
to no taxes
why wouldn't they even consider that
plan in the interim while they're
building their quote renewables
well i got to tell you i didn't think it
was possible to screw up the economy any
worse than the biden administration and
democrats already had in less than two
years
and yet here we are they've they've
managed to find a new way to make it
even worse um and you know of course you
know pete buda judge tells people who
complain about six dollars a gallon
gasoline would just go buy an electric
car and he doesn't seem to care that an
electric car costs 66 000
uh but in this under this bill it's
gonna cost you sixty two thousand
dollars uh uh instead of sixty six
thousand dollars it it's absolutely
insane and uh and it's also a massive
lie the idea that they're calling it the
inflation reduction act this is gonna
this includes 400 billion dollars in
government spending which of course is
not going to help any average american
but it is going to make inflation even
worse
this year
it's solyndra on steroids in the middle
of a recession it's even
it's dumber than dumb
i mean if you want to if it's possible
to screw up the economy anymore this
will do it even mansion said it and even
obama said it you don't raise taxes in
the middle of a recession exactly what
they're doing and of course it's going
to do nothing to lower the price at the
pump for americans and every product at
every store that gets there by a truck
that's paying a lot more for diesel
costs all of us more because that cost
gets passed on to us i don't know i i
don't see how this end truck driver is
not getting a pay raise out of this yeah
great point
all right thank you both hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else